I had become addicted to valium and I
was about 93 pounds a candid revelation
from the former Bachelorette on her new
youtube series 9 - why
the Alberta native describes moving to
Germany in her 20s to follow her
then-boyfriend
and her subsequent struggle to cope with
their breakup I went to the doctor and
I'll never forget filling out paperwork
on how depressed I was I remember on a
scale of 1 to 10 being suicidal I
remember filling everything out and just
feeling like I had nothing and that life
was over for me
the reality star says the drug helped
her suppress her emotions surrounding
the break-up but to a point where she
was numb and unmotivated but through her
eventual rise in the restaurant industry
and a push from one of her pals she
worked up the confidence to apply for
The Bachelor and the rest is history you
can't let anyone be responsible for your
own happiness that is up to you and now
I can see that because I'm in a
fulfilling loving happy relationship but
27 year old Kaitlyn was just starting to
learn that and figure that out